what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have two
deleted scenes from doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness that you're
going to want to know about both of
these opening scenes would have made the
movie a lot more dark yes the movie was
already kind of dark with some of the
scenes with the souls of the damned also
spoiler alert if you haven't seen the
movie we're about to talk about some big
spoilers like the illuminati all dying
that was pretty dark but i don't think
they were actually as dark as these two
scenes one of them of course is another
murder scene but another one involves
the illuminati and an x-men well not
really an x-men but a mutant that we
didn't see but was supposed to be in the
movie but was actually cut and this
mutant is magneto and this scene
actually involves the storyline of where
magneto is the biological father of
wanda this is a story that at one point
in time takes place in the comics it is
revealed that magneto is the biological
father of both petro and wanda and as it
turns out we were robbed of that scene
but i will say it definitely would have
made the movie darker and we'll break it
down everything you need to know in this
video and of course if you're new be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest marvel videos and
news now i guess it seems appropriate
that the first scene that we should talk
about is the opening scene or should i
say the alternate opening scene and i
should add according to the reports that
we'll talk about these scenes were
actually filmed but never made the final
cut but like i said the first scene
involves a murder from wanda not that we
didn't get enough in the movie but this
one would have set the tone right away
right from the get even quicker than it
did before because let's face it the
movie started off pretty fast and it
just kept going and going and this was
recently revealed by my buddy paul over
at heavy spoilers and like i said it's
an alternate opening sequence and he
says we would have seen mordo go visit
wanda at the very start of the movie and
it is very weird that we never saw our
earth's mordo perhaps they have
different plans but in this deleted
scene doctor strange 2 would have picked
up right where doctor strange 1 left off
with mordo going about killing all of
the sorcerers and the magical people
that was the cliffhanger they teased us
with in the post credit scene mordo was
going around killing sorcerers he
thought there were too many and of
course mordo is a main and very very big
doctor strange villain in the comics so
this would make sense however it looks
like the journey that he was planning to
go on killing all of these sorcerers was
going to be cut very very short however
keep in mind that in this scene when
they're in the earth 838 universe when
doctor strange actually talks to mordo
he tells him that the mortal in his
universe had been spending his life
right now trying to kill him so keep
that in mind clearly mordo has been
going about trying to kill strange and
other sorcerers but in this alternate
opening scene that comes to an end when
he meets wanda according to paul's
report he says mordo was going to be the
main villain that showed up in the
introduction to the movie and he'd be
used to demonstrate wanda's new ruthless
attitude in the words of paul he would
go to attack her and she'd turn him into
mom spaghetti beheading him within
seconds of his arrival it was going to
be a big way to start the film and it
instantly cemented wanda as the villain
then from here we would jump to the gap
junction which is where we would be
introduced to america chavez and
defender strange now this certainly
would have been a pretty dark way to
open up the movie a beheading scene
showing how ruthless wanda actually is
however the first time we see wanda it's
pretty much revealed that she is the
villain there's no fighting there's no
beheading but the next time we see her
she pretty much takes down the whole
camera tag and she kills a bunch of
innocent sorcerers so this scene would
have been pretty cool but it was pretty
well established from the beginning of
the movie that wanda was indeed the
villain and since they didn't actually
show this scene this leaves it open for
doctor strange 3 for morta to return so
this story could be further explored and
developed now that scene is dark in a
killing type of way but this next
deleted scene is dark on a different
level and it would have set the
illuminati up to be more of antagonists
of the film than they actually were this
was revealed by moviescope.com where
they say in the original cut of the
movie this wanda storyline was probably
the darkest thing marvel studios had
ever done in an mcu film and what
they're actually referring to is the
origin story of the wanda from the 838
universe the wanda in the illuminati's
universe in which our wanda uses to
dreamwalk now if you recall in the movie
mordo mentions to doctor strange when he
arrives in a sanctum that he had the
darkhold and that wanda could do
something far worse which was
dreamwalking so mordo knew about
dreamwalking which means that 838
universe doctor strange most likely knew
about it too and according to this
deleted scene he definitely did and the
whole illuminati did too and they
decided to attack wanda before she had
the chance to attack anybody else
according to moviescope.com they say
originally when the doctor strange
variant of that universe encounters the
darkhold he also came across the chapter
that detailed the scarlet witch prophecy
this page of course was shown to us in
one division by agatha harkness they
also reiterated it in multiverse of
madness where they said she was made to
either rule the entire multiverse or
destroy it that's the prophecy of the
scarlet witch so doctor strange of that
universe came across it and he informed
the illuminati of his findings and they
all came to the conclusion of performing
a lobotomy on their universe's wanda so
as to prevent the prophecy from ever
happening in that universe now for those
who don't know what a lobotomy is it's a
form of brain surgery that involves
severing connections in the brain's
prefrontal cortex so it's a pretty big
deal and pretty dang dark but the
article continues to say this lobotomy
would be performed by none other than
their resident telepath charles xavier
who was meant to remove wanda's access
to her abilities thus creating the
domestic wanda variant and perhaps they
actually did this because i'm sure most
people noticed the wanda in that
universe was way weaker than the wanda
in our universe when arwanda came in she
pretty much wiped the floor with her and
when she was dream walking in that body
it's safe to say that some of her powers
kind of transferred over so this would
describe more of that tame wanda however
this isn't the end of the scene they say
that in order to perform this lobotomy
they needed to consult wanda's
biological father which is where the
deleted scene with michael fassbender as
magneto would have come into play now
over the past couple of days it was
revealed that there were five cameos
that were actually shot but were cut
from the final version of the movie and
one of those cameos was said to be
michael fassbender's magneto and
according to movie scope this was the
scene that was shot and filmed now of
course this is kind of a darker story
but this is really really exciting
because they were going to acknowledge
that at one point in time in the comics
magneto is the biological father of
wanda now what's interesting is that it
doesn't say that magneto was going to be
a part of the illuminati like some of
the other cameos for example a scene
that was apparently shot and filmed was
a fight between ghost rider and wanda
now this would have been insane to see
unfortunately much like the fate of the
illuminati that we saw his would have
been the same he would have lost wanda
there's also the balder the brave scene
which apparently was going to be played
by daniel craig so we missed out on that
as well but he was also going to die so
the whole point of this scene would have
been twofold one to explain why this
wanda isn't exactly as strong as the
other and two to establish that magneto
is the biological father of wanda now
this is kind of really good news for us
in our main 616 universe because if
they're willing to say that magneto is
the biological father of wanda in
another universe they could probably say
that for ours and we do know that the
x-men and the fantastic four shouldn't
be too far away from entering the mcu
after all we did just see john krasinski
as mr fantastic it's only a matter of
time until they make their official mcu
debut in our main universe and hopefully
when they do they further explore
magneto being wanda's father and maybe
they could even bring back quicksilver
somehow but let me know what you think
about these two scenes in the comments
below would you have liked to have seen
them there was supposed to be about 40
extra minutes of the movie that were cut
and based off of everything i've heard i
personally would have preferred the
movie to have that extra 40 minutes but
let me know what you think don't forget
to leave a like and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos for live updates you can follow
me on instagram and twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof